there is a 70 year old man who is
charged with robbing a Kansas City
Kansas Bank he did it for a very unusual
reason he said he wanted to be in a jail
cell because he didn't want to be around
his wife I'm talking about Lauren's John
ripple who's charged in federal court
with the robbery of the bank of Labor on
Minnesota Avenue in Kansas City Kansas
and I've taken a look at the court
documents Ripple
showed up to the bank gave a bank teller
a note which said I have a gun give me
money most banks have a policy where you
you give someone money and the teller
did exactly that but then instead of
leaving the bank ripple took the money
and sat down in the bank lobby according
to the documents and when a bank
security guard came up to him ripple
said I'm the guy you're looking for the
guard took the money back from ripple
they basically just hung out waiting for
police to arrive and when he was
questioned by an investigator he said
yeah you know my wife and I had an
argument and uh he quote no longer
wanted to be in that situation he
actually wrote out his demand note in
front of his wife and told her he'd
rather be in jail than at home and
that's exactly what he did going to a
bank and robbing it imagine that right I
can't stand you I'm going to write
myself a demand note and go to the bank
to get myself arrested uh you can't just
use this justice system in this way can
you I know that many times when there
are arguments in couples uh you get used
to the parameters of the argument so one
of the two people will try to sort of
amp it up and do something new to show
that they're really serious this time
except this one's not really reversible
because the guy actually went and robbed
a bank and now what could happen is that
a judge could hear all of the fact and
say well I am sentencing you to house
arrest and then it would so sort of
defeat the purpose of having robbed a
bank to be sent to jail and to be away
from his wife sadly and this is sort of
a an odd story but there are some really
sad stories and we've talked about them
were people
we'll commit a crime because they either
need a place to live and they're having
trouble finding one in the real world or
they need health care and you might
remember if you've been listening to the
show for a while that back in 2012 I
told you the story of an ex-convict
named Frank Morocco who uh deliberately
went and shoplifted 23 dollars worth of
stuff from a Wegmans store deliberately
to get himself in violation of parole
and sent back to prison because he had
leukemia he needed health care and he
was out in the world without health care
uh and that is so so horrifying and as
you know the United States one of the
few countries where there's such a thing
as uh bankruptcies caused by on being
unable to pay health care bills and that
is absolutely insane now as far as the
70 year old man wanting to be in prison
to be away from his wife uh top level he
didn't kill his wife and that's a good
thing anytime I mean it I think that
this was a sort of silly use of the
justice system but if this prevented him
from becoming violent with his wife then
that is something good he will also
likely end up I mentioned this is in
federal court if he ends up in federal
prison rather than state prison usually
federal prisons are better uh I I'm sort
of really digging here to find some kind
of silver lining uh and it big picture
many times people say and do things that
they really don't mean during arguments
uh it's good to keep in mind that there
are some actions you can't really undo
and I think this absolutely qualifies
there